the left-hander eduardo rodriguez and
eddie five and four a 607 earned run
average here's the 3-2 home
and in there strike three
he dropped in a beauty to fanboy had a
great start for eduardo he gets it one
two three
eric cole's turn today
i told that slab at fenway park on a
sunday afternoon 16th start on the year
and those numbers are really really good
here's enrique hernandez
and the tall right-handers first one
swinging to drive out to left that one
way up there and it is gone
one pitch
one to nothing
red side's jumping
right on garrett cole oh talk about
being ultra aggressive by goodness so
now the socks with two men set to score
yankees have to bring the infield in and
raffi devers will climb it
swinging a high knee drive right field
watch this baby carry it has gone into
the bleachers raffy devers with number
19 a three run shot boy the red sox
continue to pound the yankees early in
the game
weaved in and missed he struck him out
beautiful change up beautiful change up
that time
by rodriguez
he's eight for 12 with the home run of
coal here's the o2 struck him out
swinging slider away
and there's one down
well that's a nice bounce back inning as
he strikes out for dugo gets two
strikeouts retires the red sox in order
and we will go to the third
always a threat to hit a mile
and in there strike three caught him
looking
those who get the jump there they go
and shot
sliding stab throw on to first he got
him
[Applause]
what a play by gonzalez
and saves the inning still four nothing
boston
jd martinez walked and scored on the
rafael devers home run in the first red
sox lead four to nothing all four in the
first
he'll swing it high twisting fly ball
deep center field judge turning it is on
to the batters eye another red sox homer
and the sox leaded five nothing over
garrett cole and the yankees goal in
trouble again
swinging a high pop into right field
frazier getting underneath
bogart's back to tag makes the catch
here comes the runner
he will score as it skips off the mound
the red sox have another run
now on top six to nothing good job good
job by vasquez man at third base gets
the ball in the air
[Applause]
strike three
got him on the slider
but the red sox scored two more runs two
hits one error one man left
[Music]
gonzalez made a great defensive play on
a ground ball hit by voigt and the
inning there's a foul tip
into the mitt for strike three was a
pitch inside
stan seems not to believe it he has an
expression of bewilderment as he walks
away
he didn't swing the bat but apparently
it just did nick the bat one and two on
her shella
and a swing and a miss he struck him out
back-to-back case
they didn't make the playoffs in the
last season of the old ballpark
strike three verdugo down looking 100
miles an hour so coal still throwing
hard
here's the pitch
strike over the inside edge and down
goes frazier looking never stops
that's in there strike three
back-to-back caves by the left-hander
who's been really sharp here this
afternoon against the yankees
two and two to renfro
swing and a miss got him on a slider
two away
so there's a runner at first no one on
here is judge
two balls two strikes nobody out runner
on first
high drive left field there it goes
see ya
over the monster a long blast for judge
a two run shot the yankees on the board
it's 6-2
past him there
fastball to strike him out he fans void
for the second time that's what he
needed badly right there you know he had
a couple of base runners base running to
lead off the game the home run or the
inning i should say then the home run
then you buzz the fastball by voight to
get that first out in the sixth
in there for strike three that one
frozen
red sox pitching today between you know
rodriguez and
now the first battle that hernandez
faces they have been pinpointing
and then hitting the corners like crazy
97 on the outside corner
yankees at first second and third
and in there to strike him out caught
him looking
what a huge out that is oh huge big
pitch
base is jammed two down
swung on popped up
santana ranging into right
backing up he makes the play and they
leave them loaded
whitlock continues to get the job done
[Applause]
be back next week 1-2 pitch
swinging a fly ball down to the left
field corner honda giving it a run can't
reach it oh my goodness
bogey into second base slides in with a
double
check out this swing
now remember the pitches he fouled off
okay the pitches he fouled off away
now he gets like a one-handed double
breaking ball again look at that he's
he's out so far out in front of it the
hand comes off the back he looks at it
he goes oh that's going to drop man
zach's trying to add on to a 6-2
advantage rafael devers with a three-run
homer and a single today
almost where it connects to the red sox
pan little lob down the left field line
that's going to fall in for a hit and it
will bring home a run as on duhart plays
it into second bogarts rounds and scores
it's a four rbi game for rafael devers
and the red sox with a little more
breathing room now
big swing and a miss on the slider to
put him away
one gun
ground ball could be two to flip the
bogey on to first the red sox turn it
easily
four six three their first double play
today
brooks krisky is going to pitch out of
their pen
christian vasquez first man to test him
here today
swinging a high fly ball left field deep
this is carrying carrying and looks and
she's gone
the socks have homered again
one two
to sanchez
swing animus and that's how it ends and
the red sox have swept the yankees again
they are a perfect 6-0 against new york
this season and in fact the winning
streak over the yankees going back to
last season
is seven straight games